قال رئيس اركان الجيش الاسرائيلي هرسي
هليفي ان الجيش سيجري تحقيقا معمقا
لاستخلاص العبر بعد مقتل 21 جنديا وضابطا
في قطاع غزه واضاف ليفي ان المعركه في غزه
ستكون طويله وان الجيش سيحتاج الى قوات
الاحتياط
مجددا نفل بك لقد سقطوا في معركه بالقرب
من السياج الحدودي خلال عمليه دفاعيه في
المنطقه الفاصله بين الدات الاسرائيليه
وغزه في مهمه غايتها الوحيده تهيئه الظروف
الامنيه لاتاحه عوده سكان منطقه غلاف غزه
الى بيوتهم بامان لهذا السبب خرجنا الى
هذه الحرب التي بدات بمحاوله وحشيه لوقف
الحياه ونحن اليوم مصممون اكثر من السابق
لاعاده الحياه الى هنا بشكل اقوى لقد عدت
للتو من المنطقه التي سقط فيها المقاتلون
وهناك التقيت بالقاده استمعت للاستنتاجات
والعبر الاوليه وكما نفعل دائما سنجري
تحقيقا معمقا وسنستقبل خلال القتال كي لا
يتكرر مثل هذا الحادث